Vaccines are celebrated for their part in fighting disease,
but a growing group of people seem to believe that they endanger our health
instead of protecting it.
The Internet is full of stories about allergic reactions,
the onset of disability, and even death following vaccination appointments,
and it's true. Vaccines can have side effects.
Let's look at how they work and how dangerous they really are.
Your immune system is a complex army of billions of cells, soldiers,
intelligence cells, and weapons factories every day.
You're attacked countless times,
but you're immune soldiers alone usually deal with that so you don't even notice
if an infection become serious though.
Our intelligence cells gather intel about the attackers and activate our weapons
factories,
you know the weapon antibodies then like targeted missiles produced specifically
to combat the invader. Unfortunately,
this process takes several days to complete.
That gives intruders a lot of time to do damage.
Contrary to popular wisdom. What doesn't kill you? It doesn't make you stronger.
Our bodies really don't want to fight serious wars over and over.
So our immune system came up with an ingenious way to get stronger and stronger
over time.
If we find an enemy that is dangerous enough to trigger our heavy weapons,
our immune system automatically creates memory cells.
Memory cells remain in our body for years in a deep sleep,
they do nothing but remember when an enemy attacks for a second time,
the slumbering memory cells awakened and order coordinated attacks and the
production of antibodies.
This is so fast and effective that many infections you beat once will never make
you sick again. You might even be immune against them forever,
which is also why little kids are constantly ill.
They don't have enough memory cells yet,
and this beautiful natural mechanism is what we build on when we use vaccines,
how vaccines work.
[inaudible]
as great as memory cells are obtaining them,
throat infection is unpleasant and sometimes dangerous.
Vaccines are a way of tricking our bodies into making memory cells and becoming
immune to a disease. They pretend to be a dangerous infection.
One way of doing this is to inject invaders that can't do harm, for example,
by killing them or by ripping them into pieces and our immune systems deal with
these kinds of vaccines pretty easily.
Sometimes it's necessary to make our immune system work harder though to produce
even more than we cells. Live. Vaccines are the real deal.
An enemy, the company back is a bigger challenge than a dead one.
But this also sounds like a sort of horrible idea. What if the germs win?
To avoid that,
we breed a sort of weak cousin of the real gem and the lab just powerful enough
to annoy the immune system and creates enough memory cells. Okay,
so these are the basic principles of vaccine use.
They provoke a natural reaction in our bodies that makes us become immune
against a very dangerous diseases.
Some like the flu virus mutates so often that we need a new vaccine every year,
but most vaccines protectors for years or even a lifetime.
But there's a catch like everything in life.
Vaccines have another side, side effects.
What are they and what happens if your child develops one?
The risks of vaccines,
it's complicated to directly compare the side effects of vaccines with the
effects of diseases. For example,
hundreds of millions of people are vaccinated against measles in the west,
but there were only 83,000 cases in Europe in 2018 so with numbers that
different,
even mild side effects can seem scary compared to the bad effects of a disease
that we don't see as much anymore.
Before the measles vaccine became available in 1963 virtually every single child
on earth contracted measles at some point,
an estimated 135 million cases in the 1950s every single year,
but aren't measles ready that dangerous in the year 2019 with our advanced
healthcare and new technologies,
are they worth the risk of vaccine side effects?
Let's do a thought experiment based on real numbers.
Imagine a developed country in a parallel world. It has good healthcare,
but people stop vaccinating. In this scenario.
Let's say 10 million children called measles. What happens?
9,800,000 door,
98% will get a high fever and a very unpleasant rash.
Up to 800,000 of them or 8% will suffer from dangerous diarrhea.
700,000 or 7% we'll suffer from an ear infection,
which can lead to permanent hearing loss.
600,000 kids or 6% will suffer from pneumonia.
The most dangerous effect of measles is alone will kill 12,000 children up to
10,000 children or 0.1% will get encephalitis,
2,500 kids or 0.025% we'll contract SSV they disease where the measles virus
lingers in their brain and kills them. A few years later,
taken together around 2.5 million children will suffer from somewhat serious
effects from Mesons and about 20,000 children will be killed by measles.
It doesn't stop here though.
The kids who beat measles are left with a severely damaged immune system that
needs a lot of time to regenerate time for other diseases to do further damage.
Aside from that,
what's almost guaranteed is that your kids will have a really bad time for about
two weeks. Okay, but what about vaccines?
It's only fat and look at these risks too.
So let's repeat our thought experiment,
but this time we vaccinate 10 million children with MMR.
What would theoretically happen here after being vaccinated,
of our 10 million kids, around 10% get a fever.
500,000 or 5% will get a mild rash up to 100 or 0.001% might have a serious
allergic reaction and we'll have to be treated up to 10 boys or 0.0001% might
get inflammation of the Genitalia and up to 10 kids in total or 0.0001% might
get the most serious side effects and Cephalitis so we've accelerated 10 million
kids in total around 120 had side effects that were somewhat serious thanks to
good medical treatment in developed regions. Almost all of them will be fine.
What about autism?
The connection of autism and vaccines stems from one source that has been
disproven countless times.
We'll link to further reading and videos in the description,
but in 2019 it's fair to say that vaccines do not cause autism.
All right, but what about deaths?
It's really hard to say if even a single one of our 10 million vaccinated kids
would die.
We really did look hard and talk to a lot of different experts.
If we ignore self reporting,
we could only come up with a tiny handful of documented cases for all the
hundreds of millions of children who received the MMR vaccine since 1971
measles are many,
many thousands of times more dangerous for your child than even the absolute
worst case of vaccine side effects.
You have to search for lethal vaccine side effects with a huge magnifying glass,
and even then,
it's very hard to find confirmed cases while deaths from measles are real and
easy to find. In 2017 alone,
110,000 people died from measles worldwide. Statistically,
today, 300 children will die of measles. One.
Since this video started, you can compare vaccines to seatbelts.
Are they aware freak accidents where someone gets killed by their seatbelt?
Well, yes,
but do you personally think it's safer to not put a seatbelt on your kid?
Wait a second. What if your kid is actually allergic?
What if none of the things we've said applies to your specific situation?
In this case,
you need to become the greatest vaccination promoter of all because if your
children can't be vaccinated, only the collective can protect them.
This is called herd immunity and it's the only thing that can protect your
unvaccinated child.
Herd immunity means that enough people are immune to a disease that it can't
spread and dies before it reaches its victims.
But to accomplish this for measles alone,
95% of the people around you need to be vaccinated.
Conclusion.
The problem with the debate about vaccines is that it's not fought on a level
playing field. While the pro vaccine side argues with studies and statistics,
the arguments against them are usually a wild mixture of gut feeling,
anecdotes and information and feelings are often immune to facts will not
convince anybody by screaming at them,
but we can't hide from the reality of water.
Anti-Vaccine conspiracies do they kill babies too young to be vaccinated?
They kill healthy children that are just unlucky.
They bring serious diseases back from the verge of extinction and the biggest
side effect of vaccines is fewer dead children.
Vaccines are one of the most powerful tools we have to eradicate the monsters
that most of us have already forgotten. Let's not bring the beasts back.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].